we have a problem that there is something
strange going on I'm almost sure that
everything we were looking for don't [ __ ] with me like it's
not mine
the [ __ ] that gave birth to them how can they be
so stupid and it was all arranged but they
're the same if they even look like twins no
tell me that the people aren't or it isn't
you you play the [ __ ]
this isn't the mine they had to
build
and I don't know what the hell you are but
we still need the guitar
if it doesn't change thank you so I
started knitting to get off  from here you are going to
have to
stand still we are going to hurt you
health to health to the people hello
that I hug you and you leave yourself as if they
were the boyfriends that you understand
the seniority to cooperate I already told you if you
behave well we will not  do nothing
but you have to cut you understand
the mice ate their tongues with
that prick and that little face two
lucas you don't have to speak you know how to speak
first things first then
when the year is the key
look I'll give you some advice and listen to me
good because I give very little advice be
good to me
the women treat me well they can
now if they treat me like an [ __ ]
those are tables but if I don't do anything to them they
just say nothing to them
and I think that even the last neighbor in
this shitty neighborhood found out
You know one thing about that, I didn't like it at all
with the shouting, he gets very nervous,
very nervous,
so stop playing little games and long the
key, long the key,
that's why
one works and the shitty edition
is just some magical mangoes.
The mouse is enough for them, just two lucas for the
money because I want to express that you
said
a class
the difficult one and he is stable
watching
there is a lot of TV of girls in the
brain
who do you think these three of
the Snow White senate are
now for the service but  the reputation
to mother
possible to start
to see if you explain what is happening to you since
now we have a while now we are going to
take out one of the voices we take out the other
what do you want I explained to you what is happening
to you that if I have denounced  or the same
is not the same
and today he told me that he wanted to take a few
days that he was tired we worked
together
as a young man he felt tired and I need to
unplug
where they work the mini font is a
cell phone company I asked
you both if we are going to  go on a trip together the
month they live on the coast but he told me
he couldn't stand it that he wanted some time
for which later we got together
and he left he wants to make a line with
our friends
now I understand friends have boobs and their
names are not diego and  gonzalo is
getting tired of me and well and he has resorts
he went with another one of my co
-workers
if he went on vacation with others
they just waited for me today
at the pools
vacations now they call him vacations do
n't shut up
nothing happens it's the most  common in the world
I did not mean that I want to say that everything is
going to be fine it
can be fine
and the only thing I have
besides with her in the office
everyone left
and I saw him
at the airport
and the sunscreen I gave  ce the plane the
very sensitive skin sunscreen
this is drinking hot chocolate he knows
that everyone everyone in the company
talks all the time
well everyone not many people for
their points they can be in your office 510
people
the strength of  maximum window like 200
it's not that big a deal you're not
angelina jolie either here your sentimental life may matter to him
no they don't talk about me it
's because of him and he doesn't live he's the son of
the commercial director oscar puterío which
finalist looks like a soap opera that's
a new  video
could make me pretty
everyone has something to say everything
from the doorman to the president of
the company
there was a queue it would not be possible the [ __ ]
mother starts
and well baby
sooner or later I am going to pass
the men are we are all the same
cheché speaks  by voice, look, I have
codes, let's see that the capable kid who
sent this [ __ ] but I'm sure he also
loves you, he can't explain it to you,
women sometimes don't understand p  But well, it
's like that, well, don't worry, why
can we help
you? Help him with paying for the therapy.
Look at the story. It's like that.
One of these days, if you want,
you ask for s
and we go and give him a scare,
a scare, if I break his arm.
or a shrimp wanting to ski what they
say is to breed they won't fit it is just
a lesson
look we can do a two for one if
you want that one we'll also give it for trola
no it's not necessary capable that now you don't
think it's necessary but think  calmer
and now it's
12 - 5 let's go quickly then the next one
I want
finally I'm going to tell
you something you have these problems we have
ours the list is to get the
same occasion brother in canada
we are seeing each other from the century
we are the twine to get it out
and  why do they tell me this
I don't know that
way you can see that the twine is going to be useful for
something
the account that should always be there
you're leaving the little plant
this had a smile well it can leave
you now you're going to cam  walk straight for her
without turning around we are going to be
looking at talca and after a while we
don't have to look at it anymore
so sexy
and